у нас сьогодні короткий брифінг присвячений
і в прошу торгую харчування прийняття нового
закону про вашу почет вишивається шляхів до
світ андська граматики сочі колада вже
давно воші у 2008-му уроки почав
рубль від і борщі проекту після тих ми
буде два десятки законопроекту
розроблена але поки не вийшла на пак
Менш кінцеву версію через 20 хвали не
розпізнається засідання комітету
верховної ради України
перетворена троянди adobe перед іншим
чотирьох законопроектах про висів свято
вірить руїн jetta new законопроект було в
наса не так і кисми на правду я на
парад попрошу гладжу рна листя на
сильну для катання про те, що правкою
вигадають не було на душі в посмішці том
що за мою 400 історії але до правильної
таблиці та на правду часті ножних
технічніше
часті визна їх ясна замість поза у нас
важливі в них замість ван їх правах я до мене
сина за раз перед іншим щось не
одягаються волина і комітетами в
подалі му найвищу раду ю.с.
повернення норми права викладати до
навантаження
в апсиді 600 року я на ворожого
досконалому законодавстві вам про два
члена початку нам це ж не для кого
подарункових супротивників максимально 901
щоб зварювальні в краї велетня і навіть
ним чого в польшу чаррови цієї
програмою каторгу з самих викладати
iv і не знаю найважливіших так і
адміністративних гарпун для підвищення
кістки навчання
також ми говоримо про європейський до
світла в Європі
глада ніж від 230 до початкового
навантаження
цьому наші 900 га dance озвучено
абсолютно на світі на абсолютну
автоматично виробляє йдуть а ви що
курсу читаються
вас повний вигляд дачі тому що ви
цвинтар просто не можете надсилати
щось дістати ні години підготуйте я
тісних початкових курсів випадково
пропустіть змінений до 600
автоматично до європейських стандартів
європейських вимахав акція рук у тому вона
прям кузов буде ми підкова означати
що ми лаємося на премію значення нова
навіть не обидва знають і желе нас важливі
військової кільки
а я кисть на іржання сюди і їх важливі
зрадники б відрізняються законопроектом
мають рацію що свята в порно наші речі з
вас теж добра знаєте назвав сам
законопроекту чоловік тобі теж довго
говорила весь червоний чекаю весь міни їд
такі
у створ не національна і національна
нс твій а кості вище свити леку його
кінного там і валика відчувають їх
функція кіно сьогодні погла даний на
міністерство святі наука у тому числі
особи назву про кандидата я буду тут
не ось ці самим-агенством а і
кабуто складу тася про цінники вищих
початкових закладі в спартаку в мережі
процедурки у студенті ви тут від свободи
абсолютно інджі та формат управлінського
роману pureview священним міністерством
і саме
національне нсд ось і моя біцуха стіну
повна важливий адміністративного
people you keep передадуть і буду таким
чином децентралізовані змінну ширину
і моделлю таку саму на даєте і більше
прав студентам у плані вибору
спеціальності затвор уживаються
мінімально
адже соток курсовики студенти зможе
апарату суді на ремені 20 5 вид сотки
тут вона за гауті все змін і в принципі
ванни в будинку в принципі ці таблиці
правий які ви по батькові ще раз у
минулому або катаєшся жорстко були
клоновані і технічні просто на
в'єтнам був їх у 22 ти назвав у
законопроекті зображена та ідеологія
кобила заклада але зараз роботу групи
дубровського та кобила Петро його на широку
суддівський аромат пензлем на сьогодні
що я може позначитися робота
міністерства святі наука
тут пилку вані езри якому відвикла
дача мазі студентами ми бачимо що їду ж
на усмішку захід відразу свічка низька з при
але то треба що це законопроект було
прийнято ми розуміємо а що на сьогодні з у
тайців парламенті їжу дружини стабільну ми
знаємо обсмажте дайкірі, які я заношу
в газі вкола просто там вже чого на
розуміти важливо вести його закону право
рахунок свиту намагаються дати плутайте з
проходимо
Петро і мотатися із законопроекту просто
там облік до Польщі кульовий інтерес вищих
початкових закладемо щоб запускати що
це рожевий так цик університеті
академії.
думаю я знаю що вже сватаються дати
плутати з тим шепса так і буду Петро їм
вона в іншому вчить вони законопроекту та
щоб наздоганяти та сесії ми прийняли багато
і великими розведеннями ви цю свято думаю я
з девайсом ще парламенту така зможемо
консулу 22 ккал осьового харчування та
прийняті за і дуже важливий законопроект